myanmar was supposed to mark an exercise
in democracy on monday
but instead the military rounded up the
nation's democratically elected
leadership including
onsongsu chi it then announced a coup on
military-run tv
ema tobiandi the state of emergency
is in effect nationwide and the duration
of the state of emergency
is set to one year
military chief min clang now rules the
country
monday was to be the first session of a
new parliament after onsongsuchi's party
the national league for democracy won a
landslide victory in november
recently the army made accusations of
election fraud
and tension between the civilian
government and the military increased
last week
when a general refused to rule out the
possibility of a coup
like this member of parliament nld
leaders and military critics were taken
into detention before dawn this is our
worst nightmare
quite clearly this is the myanmar
military
uh scrapping the democratic experiment
uh the
you know you're talking about a party
that won a
landslide election truly a landslide
election
and all of a sudden we have uh aung
suchi we have the president and other
top people
under detention and a state of emergency
manufactured by the military to justify
a year-long seizure of power
there's a growing list of nations
expressing concern over the situation
in myanmar as well as the united nations
the u.s state department has called on
the military to release all those who
have been detained
australia's prime minister says his
country is keeping a close watch
well these are rather disturbing
developments i'm aware of those
troubling reports and the foreign
minister
has been following them the banks in
myanmar have shot due to poor internet
connection and not knowing what might
come next
people are stocking up on supplies scott
heidler al jazeera